j'ai offert une petite interview pour
pécho est ce que pour pécho qui pour
pécho a déjà fait croire qu'il était
hyper pote avec une célébrité ou une
personne très importante qu'il a déjà
fait ce bond bernard qu' une personne
connue bernard oui oui oui oui oui oui
j'ai dit que j'étais très ami avec plein
de gens célèbres oui ça arrange ça fait
rêver donc moi je suis pour le rêve je
fais rêver rien que de me regarder on va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
laisser bernard montiel et elle s'est
barrée
jonathan toews a abaissé sa non non et
non plus alors jamais benjamin castaldi
non jaber chose que vous êtes déjà
connus voilà ce que je suis le petit
fils de la 71ème je cachais plus tôt
jean michel mr mois plusieurs fois on
m'a proposé de succomber à mon pseudo
charme si je te donner votre numéro de
téléphone et à leur donner et je te
donne évidemment mais c'est vrai comment
avec lame soit au numéro m'insérer vous
le donne à qui bat aux filles qui sont
en boîte n'avons jamais appelé un os qui
a déjà menti sur son âge mais genre de
beaucoup jean-michel aller
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
les gens se trouvent naturellement à ce
que les gens pensent pas quand j'ai
cinquante jours les gens ne croient pas
ils disent non pas du tout me taussat à
42,38 la gemmi pas je dis oui c'est vrai
que j'aime bien me dire mais bon vous
avez déjà menti sur votre âge vous c'est
fait jonathan
ouais mais à deux trois ans près tu vois
on n'était pas sur des vraies à venise
en voir non pas de nous des petits des
petits dés tu vois là a dit j'ai 21 ans
[Rires]
qui est qu'est ce qui se vend à quatre
mois après non mais faire basculer dans
l'année l'année d'après dans le siècle
dans un train home à contrôler pour ma
carte bleue oui et tout et tout j'ai
préféré donner de noms mais c'est
vraiment j'aime bien raison
rené et toi tu as déjà menti je marie
parce que quand tu te dis que tu as une
crèche qui voudraient me dis moi oui
c'est ça le député il est tellement fait
que moi je d'ivoire j'aurais 73 ans le
premier des sahraouis depuis neiges
jeudi comme kg 73 je suis dans ma 60 est
troisième avec bien sûr le prouver dès
samedi basculer assez cents à 14 heures
que le chat agathois et alors où est né
le concept vous nous permettez
ouais pas me citer pause pour réfléchir
à tout ça